Traduttore: Cristina Mantione
Revisore: Michele Gianella
- Favara-Parigi, sola andata.
- Favara-Parigi
andata e ritorno, vuoi dire.
- Miii, Viola. Sempre a puntualizzare.
- No, Carla, sei tu
che ripeti sempre la stessa frase:
"Favara-Parigi, sola andata."
- Viola! Smettila!
- D'accordo.
Anche se quando dici
queste cose ti farei...
non so che ti farei.
Carla? Sveglia, mi avevi promesso
una bella storia d'amore e fantasia.
Hai ragione, ma in parte
la storia la conosci già.
Anzi, la vivi:
tu e io, mamma e papà,
i Sette Cortili, Favara, Parigi...
- Confusionaria come sempre.
- Ma no! Tu sei a Favara,
lo sai perché sei a Favara?
- Boh, sì, in parte...
- Conosci Andrea Bartoli
e Florinda Saieva?
“Psichiatriaaa, venitevi
a prendere a mia sorella!"
(Risate)
- Ma certo che li conosco,
sono mamma e papà.
- Conosci l'inizio della loro
storia d'amore?
- In parte.
-Sai cosa hanno fatto a Favara?
- Forse…
- Viola, guarda che te le do, eh!
- Dai, scherzo. Stai calmina…
(Risate)
- Sì, so qualcosa. E voi, lo sapete?
- Mamma mamma, racconta a tutti
com'è andata questa storia.
(Applausi)
Probabilmente, loro vi hanno incuriositi.
Io vi racconterò la storia
di Favara e di Farm.
Ma vi racconterò soprattutto
quella che è la mia storia,
la mia storia d'amore:
quella tra me e Andrea.
Sin da subito noi abbiamo capito
che il matrimonio non sarebbe mai stato
un punto di arrivo,
ma un punto di partenza.
E quindi, perché questo amore
durasse nel tempo,
dovevamo nutrirlo e coltivarlo.
Andrea è una persona
molto esterofila, un sognatore.
Io sono pazza, un po’ pazzerella.
Poi sono un po’ estroversa, si vede no?
E poi sono la sesta
- dico la sesta - di sei sorelle,
e quindi in quanto tale molto irrequieta.
Per cui, quando ci siamo innamorati,
abbiamo deciso che la nostra vita
doveva diventare
il nostro progetto di vita.
Allora, quando aspettavo Carla,
che è la più grande,
abbiamo deciso di prendere in affitto
una piccola casetta a Parigi.
Una città romantica, sexy;
e anche molto stimolante,
per due appassionati
di arte contemporanea come noi.
E lì, abbiamo costruito
il nostro nido d'amore.
Però Carla doveva andare a scuola,
e ci siamo interrogati:
rimaniamo a Parigi
o torniamo in Sicilia,
torniamo a Favara, che è il mio paese?
Restare a Parigi significava rincorrerci,
voli permettendo;
per cui abbiamo deciso
di tornare a Favara,
dove avremmo potuto vivere insieme
il nostro quotidiano.
- Mamma! Ti devo interrompere.
Mamma, io c'ero,
perché non avete pensato a me?
Perché avete scelto per me?
Perché avete creduto
al vostro progetto di vita,
senza pensare che a Parigi avrei potuto -
avremmo potuto, io e Viola
che comunque sarebbe arrivata,
avere più possibilità per le nostre vite?
Mi stavi togliendo del tempo
che dedicavi a delle case vecchie.
A Parigi stavamo sempre insieme,
mi portavi ai parchi.
Tornati in Sicilia invece,
ti dedicavi, quasi esclusivamente,
a quattro catapecchie.
- In realtà, tornando in Sicilia
abbiamo pensato a loro,
abbiamo pensato al nostro futuro.
Perché io e Andrea
ci siamo fatti una promessa:
vivere a Favara, ma senza lamentarci,
senza pensare che Parigi
sarebbe stata più bella di Favara.
Senza aspettare, soprattutto,
che nessuno cambiasse il nostro destino.
Vivere a casa nostra, stare bene,
e darci anche un ruolo
all'interno di quella società.
Per cui, nel centro storico di Favara,
ormai quasi totalmente abbandonato,
abbiamo deciso di acquistare
delle piccole casette.
E iniziammo a ristrutturarle.
Per molti, quella ristrutturazione
sembrava rappresentare,
anche in quel caso, un punto di arrivo.
Invece, per noi, rappresentò
un punto di partenza.
Lì nacque il nostro progetto.
E sebbene avessimo parlato
con l'amministrazione dell'epoca,
con gli abitanti di Favara,
con i nostri amici,
con le signore che abitavano
ai Sette Cortili,
quel 25 giugno del 2010
sembrò come se a Favara
fossero atterrati gli extraterrestri.
In realtà, la gente non capiva
che cosa stesse succedendo,
che cosa volevamo fare
di quei Sette Cortili.
Forse volevamo comandare la città.
Ma invece no.
Le case, inizialmente,
si colorarono di bianco,
iniziarono a essere decorate
da alcune opere d'arte, da fotografie;
e, subito, quasi sembrò
che tutto fosse cambiato,
addirittura [con] queste lumache giganti
installate all'interno della città,
fino a giungere a quello
che oggi sono i Sette Cortili,
dove noi issammo la nostra bandiera,
la Happiness Flag.
- La bandiera della felicità!
- Sì, la bandiera della felicità.
La bandiera di chi vuole vivere
in un mondo migliore
e fare di tutto
perché questo accada.
Ma anche la bandiera
di chi vuole condividere.
Perché, sapete, molto spesso si pensa
che la condivisione
sia un atto di sottrazione.
Perché se noi abbiamo una cosa,
e la dividiamo in due,
pensiamo di averne metà ciascuno.
E invece no.
La condivisione è un atto
di moltiplicazione.
E da quel giorno,
non ci siamo mai più fermati.
Abbiamo continuato a rendere
quegli spazi sempre più belli.
Abbiamo condiviso anche quegli spazi.
Sì, perché in fondo a Favara
è questo che è successo:
noi abbiamo condiviso le nostre idee,
le nostre risorse, le nostre conoscenze;
abbiamo iniziato a organizzare
delle mostre, mostre d'arte;
abbiamo invitato sempre gente speciale;
abbiamo organizzato
dei workshop di autocostruzione.
I nostri bambini
hanno avuto la possibilità
di fare dei laboratori di statue viventi,
e non ci siamo mai più fermati,
sempre [con] gente straordinaria,
gente migliore di noi.
Ecco, allora abbiamo anche iniziato
dei percorsi formativi,
come SOU, la scuola
di architettura per bambini,
una scuola dove vogliamo
che i nostri bambini
possano pensare liberamente,
possano sviluppare un senso critico,
possano essere abituati
alla magia della creatività.
Ma possano anche sperimentare.
Perché in fondo,
se noi partiamo dal futuro,
se partiamo dai nostri bambini,
domani possiamo avere
dei cittadini migliori,
degli amministratori migliori,
e probabilmente anche noi,
da anziani, diventeremmo migliori,
È solo condividendo con loro
e dandogli la possibilità, anche,
di iniziare a pensare
che l'impossibile
possa diventare possibile.
Intanto, a Favara,
i turisti iniziavano a arrivare.
E, sapete, tutte quelle persone
che all'inizio non capivano,
o comunque molte di loro,
iniziarono a volerci bene.
Iniziarono a rendersi conto
che a Favara le cose si potevano fare.
Allora iniziarono anche loro
a essere partecipi di questo processo,
a far parte della nostra comunità.
E iniziarono a fare dei luoghi bellissimi,
più belli magari dei nostri.
Pensate: a Favara a noi avevamo,
nel 2010, 19 posti letto.
Oggi ne abbiamo 250, [di] posti letto.
La piazza, che prima era un maracanà,
oggi è diventato un luogo
che pullula di pizzerie, locali, pub.
E i palazzi nobiliari, che la circondano,
sono stati quasi
interamente ristrutturati.
- Wow! È come se un regno perduto
fosse stato ricostruito
dalle sue stesse fondamenta,
con cavalieri dall'armatura scintillante,
aiutati dagli abitanti,
a cui serviva soltanto una spinta,
per ritornare combattivi
e ridare luce al regno.
- Sì, sì, fra un po' parliamo
di Re Artù, di Ginevra,
di Harry Potter o della pietra filosofale,
e vissero tutti felici e contenti!
- Be', in fondo,
noi viviamo la nostra fiaba.
Noi a Favara siamo felici,
perché a Favara puoi vivere
delle esperienze intense.
Puoi incontrare gente straordinaria.
Farm è una sorta di qasbah siciliana.
Entri, e trovi l’inaspettato.
In un centro storico.
Poi, se ancora ti addentri,
ti può capitare, sbirciando,
di trovare un agrumeto profumatissimo,
e poi trovi loro.
Loro sono le signore
che abitano ai Sette Cortili.
Vi assicuro che sono le nostre
migliori mediatrici culturali.
Sono la zia Rosa,
la zia Maria, la zia Antonia.
Loro ci interrogano e ci chiedono -
vi racconto, una volta la Zia Maria,
che noi abbiamo rinominato
La Regina dei Sette Cortili -
arrivò questo artista coreano,
Dong Bertin, un architetto.
Allora, lui con aplomb,
un ragazzo molto composto,
timido come può essere
una persona asiatica molto educata.
Lei lo guardò e disse: “Ah, molto lieta."
Lo tirò a sé,
lo abbracciò, lo baciò,
come se fosse il nipote
arrivato da lontano.
Per di più, lo invitò
a prendere il caffè a casa sua.
Il bello di Farm è che,
se capiti un giorno qualsiasi,
puoi incontrare i ragazzi
del Politecnico di Milano
che, magari, lavorano alla progettazione
degli immobili ancora da ristrutturare.
Oppure, i ragazzi di "Move",
che sono dei ballerini
che vengono a fare delle residenze.
O Vincenzo, un ragazzo siciliano,
che ha studiato prima
negli Stati Uniti poi in Inghilterra
e poi è tornato in Sicilia,
perché vuole fare
il motivatore, nella sua terra.
Oppure ancora, i ragazzi - bambini -
alla scuola di architettura
che progettano degli orti
urbani per la città.
Perché Farm, in fondo,
è uno stato dell'anima, un modo di vivere.
E qualcuno ha provato
a teorizzare questo "Effetto Farm",
perché io, oggi, sono qui
a raccontarvi di questa esperienza,
ma probabilmente,
non riuscirò a farlo bene.
Qualcuno ha provato
a teorizzare questo effetto,
che è un effetto rigenerante,
che crea fiducia e senso di possibilità,
voglia di cambiamento,
senso di orgoglio, di appartenenza.
Perché in realtà,
a Favara sta succedendo
realmente qualcosa di importante.
C'è chi dice che non
avrebbe mai immaginato
di poter aprire un locale
o iniziare un'attività a Favara.
E grazie a Farm, lo sta facendo.
Probabilmente questo
perché il nostro virus,
che forse è un virus buono,
sta iniziando a diffondersi,
lo stiamo contagiando.
E i nostri giovani. oggi,
vivono in maniera diversa
perché il cambiamento,
apparentemente solo economico,
non è [solo economico].
Perché è un cambiamento culturale,
un cambiamento sociale;
perché oggi i giovani
si vestono come vogliono,
vivono la propria sessualità
in maniera diversa e più libera,
e anche i loro percorsi formativi
sono trasversali,
perché quando io ho scelto,
dovevo scegliere quello che dovevo fare,
per me c'erano cinque professioni.
Io potevo fare: l'architetto;
giurisprudenza,
che ti apre tutte le porte -
a me ha aperto quella
che mi ha fatto capire
che non dovevo fare il giurista;
l'ingegnere e il medico.
Invece, oggi i nostri giovani
pensano anche in maniera trasversale
perché in fondo siamo cresciuti
in una società
(Risate)
in cui...
(Applausi)
valiamo per il lavoro che facciamo
e lo stipendio che percepiamo.
E poi la macchina, le case -
a seconda di quante case abbiamo,
per come ci vestiamo,
per le amicizie che frequentiamo.
Poi, torniamo a casa
e ci rendiamo conto
che abbiamo vissuto la vita
che gli altri vorrebbero
che noi vivessimo.
E abbiamo fatto le scelte
che gli altri vorrebbero
che noi facessimo.
E lasciamo a casa noi stessi,
dimentichiamo di essere noi stessi.
Questo effetto, questo spirito invece,
quest'aria che si respira dentro Farm
dipende da infinite combinazioni:
combinazioni di idee,
competenze e conoscenze
che al suo interno si incontrano.
Farm è oggi un posto straordinario
attraversato da architetti
artisti, designer,
da gente fantastica.
E dove c'è una forza umana e creativa
che dimostra che Farm è un posto speciale,
che lo rende anche diverso
da tutti gli altri Centri Culturali.
Perché oggi Favara, e non solo Farm,
si scoprono come luogo
internazionale, interessante,
attraversato da turisti,
da tanta gente speciale.
Questi sono tutti nostri amici,
e loro dimostrano veramente
che il vento su Favara è cambiato
e nessuno, nessuno mai avrebbe pensato
che la città poteva cambiare
in così poco tempo,
e soprattutto che i Media
ne potessero parlare in maniera positiva.
Perché, in fondo,
Farm è un progetto impossibile,
diventato possibile.
- Adesso capiamo perché Favara
è la città più bella del mondo.
Sì, perché Favara - e Farm, soprattutto -
è il progetto di una vita,
della nostra vita.
E soprattutto,
se vi va di essere dei nostri,
veniteci a trovare
e ci aiuterete a cambiare
questo piccolo pezzo di mondo.
Vi aspettiamo a Favara.
(Applausi)